laurel goddari is a driver
and shows us pictures from a recent work
trip to bosangua
a town 300 kilometers north of the
capital bungie
shortly after he took these photos he
says armed men
attacked and he had to flee he's worried
about relatives who live in the town
he blames rebel groups calling
themselves the patriots coalition for
change
or cpc for the later security crisis in
the central african republic
has been told the town is almost empty
some armed elements
are harassing civilians to give up their
electoral card
others are hiding in the church as far
as i know
there cannot be a proper election in
basangoa
president faustina archangel adera has
asked people to come out and vote
urging those in bongi to be vigilant
with concerns the violence may
intimidate voters
and undermine the polls the government
is looking to provide reassurance
you have countries throughout the world
where there is no war
let's say like this and where
people decide not to vote and you have a
level of of what is participation
which is low it doesn't mean that this
election is not credible
more than 12 000 peacekeepers from the
u.n mission minusca
are barking cr security forces troops
recently sent by rwanda
russian military instructors and private
security contractors
are also on the ground all of this
instability that you're referring
to is localized in several communities
in the western part of the country
and that's been ongoing for a week a
petition filed by seven
opposition candidates to postpone the
election was rejected by the
constitutional court
17 presidential candidates have been
cleared
to run for the election one has
withdrawn his candidacy
citing security reasons most are
promising to
finally bring peace back to central
african republic
revive the economy and provide basic
services
car has numerous gold diamond and
uranium deposits
as well as other natural resources yet
it's one of the poorest and most
unstable
countries in the world more than half
the population of 5 million needs aid
some people here in the capital told us
all they want
is a dignified life and to get to the
other side of the polls
safely catherine saw al jazeera bongi